here are the best high-end products I
tested in 2022 let's start with face
products the Nars light reflecting
Advanced Skin Care Foundation is so
lightweight on the skin the coverage is
on the light to medium side but I
definitely think you can build it up
without it getting cakey it makes your
skin look really fresh and dewy without
looking oily the house lapse Foundation
Blends into the skin seamlessly the
coverage is on the lighter side but
still buildable it has skin care
ingredients in it and it actually feels
like skin care it feels like you have
absolutely nothing on your face all of
my other products blend on top of this
beautifully so this Foundation is a 10
out of 10 for me this is the summer
Friday's sheer skin tin it's supposed to
be lightweight hydrating and very
natural on the skin I definitely think
it's all of those things the coverage is
obviously sheer but it evened out my
skin nicely this is a great everyday
skin tint I'm not a pot concealer kind
of person but I really love this REM
sweetener concealer this concealer looks
thicker than it feels I was actually
surprised at how how lightweight it felt
when I was blending it out and the
coverage with this is amazing the cosas
revealer concealer is so easy to work
with and blends out so quickly the
coverage is a bit lighter than medium to
me but it covers enough I also love the
cloud set setting powder it Smooths
everything out almost instantly and it
just gives a really soft blurred look
the one size Beauty cheat Clapper 3D
blush Trio has three different formulas
a flex cream a full impact matte and a
hyper Sheen these are really pigmented
and they just look beautiful and smooth
on the skin there are just so many
different ways you can use it and all
the formulas work together so nicely the
made for shade bronze and sculpture is
also very pigmented and adds a nice
bronzy warmth to the skin this is the
Merit bronze balm and it's supposedly
the easiest bronzer ever it's definitely
one of the easiest bronzers I think I've
ever used it takes little to no effort
to blend this out and it didn't break up
the product I already had on the house
Labs bio blurring loose setting powder
definitely does blur the skin and sets
your makeup with out making it look dry
or cakey it's so soft and finely milled
and it's also talc free which is great
moving on to eye products this is the
danessa myrick's beauty lightwork 4
Transcendence palette it has four
different formulas velvet chromes which
are color shifting powders pressed
Chrome flakes which are flaky Toppers
glass metallics which are Super
reflective powders and aqua chromes
which are water activated duochrome
pigments there is so much going on in
this palette but all the formulas apply
beautifully it's extremely pricey and I
did get some slight Fallout but the
quality is there and I think it's so
much more versatile than it looks plus
it can be used on the face too this is
the KVD Dazzle long wear eyeshadow stick
it's supposed to be a one and done type
of product so you don't need primer you
just swipe it on and blend it really
does glide on easily and it has so much
glitter and Shimmer in it it's like a
way to do glitter without any of the
mess these are the collido's Epiphany
glow Melton eyeliners they're all
multi-chrome so they have these really
cool colors shifts these are so easy to
apply and the formula is really smooth
this Mac Max stack mascara is super
volumizing which I love it gives your
lashes an instant lift and I have really
straight lashes I think it makes them
look long and full without looking
clumpy next let's talk about lip
products the Fenty skin plush put in
intensive recovery lip mask feels so
moisturizing and plush on the lips the
formula is very thick but I personally
love that in a lip mask my lips were so
much more soft and hydrated after using
this mask consistently I'm obsessed with
the summer Friday's Lip Butter bombs the
formula is on the thicker side but not
sticky they feel really moisturizing and
I like how they give an almost lip gloss
effect they all give a pretty subtle
wash of color and they have this nice
vanilla scent that's not overpowering
the item Beauty lip quit moisturizing
lip oil smells amazing kind of peachy
the color is actually a little more
pigmented than I was expecting for a lip
oil but I think it's so pretty it feels
super nourishing and it just makes your
your lips look so juicy this is The
Hourglass Cosmetics Phantom volumizing
glossy balm it's supposed to be a lip
balm lip plumper and lip gloss all in
one product they have this really nice
cooling effect and they do feel like a
super moisturizing lip balm but have
this High shine finish like a gloss it
didn't do much for me in terms of
Plumping but I do love how these look
and feel on the lips the rare Beauty
kind words matte lipsticks and lip
liners are the most comfortable matte
lip products the lip liner is super
smooth even though it's matte it doesn't
drag or pull on the lips plus it's a
Twist up which I love the lipstick is so
creamy and pigmented you could probably
put this on in one swipe this is the
Nars power matte lipstick it has a
really amazing color payoff the texture
is so unique it's this soft powdery
comfortable kind of matte that actually
feels really nice on the lips and it's
transfer proof I highly recommend this
one this is the Fenty Beauty icon semi
matte refillable lipstick so the case
and the actual lipstick are sold
separately and then you assemble them
together the pigment is in incredible
and totally full coverage it's just a
very creamy formula that feels so smooth
and hydrating on the lips the house
lap's Atomic Chic lip lacquer is one of
those transfer proof glossy lipsticks so
you shake the product well and then
apply it the pigment in this really
shocked me it was so vibrant it almost
looked neon I didn't need more than one
layer for full coverage and it was so
glossy